[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation en
association avec TV 78 jusqu'au 10 juin
l'association Les 400 coups organisent
la balade de printemps 2023 et pour en
parler avec nous je suis aujourd'hui
avec eux de la Brusse directeur des 400
coups bonjour bonjour alors pour
commencer on va présenter votre
association aux éditeurs les 400 coups
qu'est-ce que c'est alors c'est ce qu'on
appelle un opérateur culturel dont
l'objectif est de développer la question
du spectacle vivant je ne publique pour
les jeunes l'enfance et l'adolescence
sur le territoire de de la Communauté
Urbaine Grand Paris seneweez et plus
globalement plus généralement sur dans
l'ensemble de la vallée de la Seine mais
le l'association a été créée au moment
de la création de cette grande
communauté urbaine qui avait regroupé 6
de PCI et la question c'était comment
est-ce qu'on harmonise un petit peu
plein d'initiatives très très disparate
sur l'ensemble des 73 communes donc
notre notre objectif c'est à la fois de
rendre un peu cohérent le travail auprès
des jeunes publics sur ce territoire et
en même temps de le développer parce
qu'ils ont s'est rendu compte très vite
qu'il y avait pas mal de manque en
termes d'offres pour les pour les jeunes
publics voilà votre ambition première
c'est justement de vous tourner vers les
jeunes publics quels sont vos ambitions
en termes de culture sur le territoire
de la vallée de la Seine auprès de ces
jeunes publics
la première ambition est comme je viens
de le dire de de leur proposer la
possibilité de de découvrir le spectacle
le spectacle vivant parce que dans cette
dans cette vallée de la Seigne il y a
quelques théâtres qui qui déjà programme
beaucoup de jeunes publics mais il y a
des endroits aussi très très isolés des
petites communes rurales même certaines
villes qui ont peu de peu de
programmation donc voilà l'objectif
c'est que de que tout le monde puisse
puisse avoir cette possibilité de de
fréquentation des oeuvres comme on dit
dans le métier qui n'est pas possible
partout
avec cette problématique des transports
qui qui est très très gagnante sur la
communauté urbaine je sais pas quand on
habite à Limay qui est quand même une
grande ville c'est très compliqué pour
des élèves d'aller voir un spectacle à
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine ou des choses
comme ça donc l'idée c'est de se
rapprocher de ces publics pour leur
permettre une fréquentation des œuvres
car justement depuis combien de temps
est-ce que vous vous existez et ce que
ces ambitions parce qu'il y a déjà un
bilan à faire sur ses ambitions est-ce
que ça fonctionne alors c'est un petit
peu compliqué parce qu'en fait
l'association a été créée donc comme je
disais plus ou moins en même temps que
la création de cette grande communauté
urbaine et les premières balades de
saison qui sont notre terre de Lens une
certaine façon pour développer le
spectacle ben c'était 2020 donc deux ans
de covid donc le bilan est un petit peu
compliqué les les vrais la vraie
programmation n'a pu être menée que la
saison dernière donc voilà on a très peu
de recul encore mais bah on se bagarre
on s'est bagarré même pendant les temps
de covid mais voilà c'est les choses se
mettent en place doucement et cette
année devrait pas y avoir de problème
alors justement cette année la de
printemps revient pour une nouvelle
édition vous proposer plusieurs
spectacles jusqu'au 10 juin et dans
plusieurs communes de la vallée de la
Seine pourquoi vouloir séparer la
programmation dans plusieurs salles de
spectacles est-ce que c'est justement
pour attirer le plus de publics possible
oui et puis c'est comme je disais pour
pour aller au plus proche des publics
nous nous disposons pas de lieu en
propre on n'a pas de théâtre à nous
d'une certaine façon donc de toute façon
notre travail notre ADN c'est de d'aller
à droite à gauche ici ailleurs sur le
territoire en travaillant des
partenariats avec des structures
culturelles avec des théâtres avec des
communes avec des médiathèques des des
petites communes donc effectivement on
est on est en balade toute l'année c'est
pour ça que ça s'appelle comme ça donc
en fait on développe trois balades de
saison sur sur l'année une à l'automne
une en hiver et une au printemps comme
on est là et parmi les spectacles
bouillent la petite goulue donc il sera
également proposé le 7 juin ou encore
Odysseus ce 31 mai ont intégré la
programmation de la balade le printemps
quels sont les spécificités spécificités
pardon de ces deux pièces de théâtre
alors bouille la particularité c'est que
ça s'adresse à la petite enfance la
compagnie le propose à partir de 18 mois
c'est un spectacle qui du coup est assez
musical
et un peu théâtre d'objets musicales
évidemment il y a pas du texte
énormément sur pour des tranches d'âge
de si petite et puis ce qui est amusant
aussi avec ce bruit c'est que à l'issue
du spectacle il y a on peut
l'accompagner propose un pique-nique
imaginaire c'est à dire que les enfants
avec leurs parents vont faire semblant
de manger dans un espace voilà il y a
une espèce de jeu de rôle d'une certaine
façon autour de la nourriture qui est la
petite goulue qui est qui est proposée
quant à Odysseus là c'est c'est une
forme clooneesque avec deux comédiennes
qui qui ont le nez rouge quand on
regarde les les images et qui proposent
sous forme de clown de raconter
l'histoire du lycée
à deux et voilà sous forme un petit peu
décalé donc c'est à la fois
c'est à la fois didactique d'une
certaine façon ça ça parle d'Homère et
de et d'Ulysse mais en même temps de
façon très décalée avec ce jeu de clown
qui devrait être très amusant pour les
enfants quoi et le spectacle sont
accessibles en live évoqué à partir de 6
ou 8 ans hein des spectacles est
accessible à partir de de 18 mois donc
ce sont des spectacles pour pour la
famille mais surtout accessible à la
jeune génération qui fait partie de
votre ADN on va parler d'un autre
spectacle le 7 juin à 10h30 c'est le
spectacle boucle d'eau qui sera présenté
à l'espace culturel Christiane Faure à
Limay qu'est-ce qui attend le public
alors boucle d'eau c'est aussi un
spectacle qui est accessible très jeune
je crois que je crois que c'est un an il
le propose comme ça voir un petit peu
avant même donc c'est une compagnie la
compagnie du porte-voix qui est qui sont
des gens qui depuis très longtemps
travaillent en direction des des jeunes
et des très jeunes publics et là c'est
un spectacle purement musical
avec des belles images aussi mais voilà
ce sont deux musiciens qui qui ont cette
habitude depuis des années encore une
fois de s'adresser aux plus jeunes par
par le biais de la musique par l'éveil
musical d'une certaine façon et c'est
très poétique très joli et voilà c'est
c'est une façon de plonger doucement
dans quand on est très jeune comme ça
dans dans le monde du spectacle vivant
de découvrir
cet univers particulier une autre
représentation est prévue le 10 juin
cette fois la médiathèque des des murs
toujours le 7 juin mais à 15h le
spectacle le Tilda et rose au Chaplin à
Mantes-la-Jolie de quoi va-t-on parler
alors là on s'adresse un petit peu au
plus grand même si c'est accessible à
partir de 8 ans et puis pour les
collégiens alors ce qu'on peut dire de
ce spectacle c'est que c'est une
création donc aussi notre volonté sur le
territoire c'est aussi de défendre de
faire venir des spectacles qu'on a qu'on
a vu qu'on trouve beau et qu'on a envie
de faire partager au public mais aussi
de faire confiance commence à des
compagnies qu'on a repéré pour pour les
aider à
se lancer et donc là la compagnie du
pépin qui propose s'ils d'aérose va
jouer aux dates que vous avez données
c'est toutes premières représentations
donc qui là aussi c'est un duo un duo
féminin nouveau et qui pas parle dans en
fait de la disparition de la mort de
façon aussi assez poétique assez assez
décalé pour pas évidemment être de front
on va pas on va pas agresser les enfants
avec ces questions là en même temps
elles existent donc c'est une façon
d'aborder des thèmes sérieux de ouais
pas par la poésie par rapport en fait
c'est une petite fille qui retrouve sa
grand-mère qui a disparu voilà on sait
pas très bien on devine qui a qui est un
décès mais tout est assez dans les lames
d'une certaine façon après je peux pas
en dire beaucoup plus parce que moi j'ai
lu le texte mais je n'ai pas encore vu
vu que ça sera ils sont en train elles
sont en train de finir leur spectacle et
c'est donc c'est à ne pas louper le 10
juin c'est un spectacle de lecture qui
est proposé à partir de 8 ans alors
Roche-Guyon qu'est-ce que ça signifie
est-ce que c'est un spectacle interactif
alors non pas spécialement interactif là
pour le coup c'est nous-mêmes les 400
coups qui le qui le proposeront en
général on fait venir des compagnies
qu'on diffuse sur le territoire là on a
c'est un projet que qu'on mène
nous-mêmes avec